-Now, you both are sisters,
and you're obviously close,
but I wanted to see
just how close you are
in a game we like to call,
"Know Your Sis."
Now, here's how it works.
One of you will wear
noise-canceling headphones
while the other answers
a question about you.
And then you'll
take the headphones off,
and we'll see
if your answer matches.
Make sense?
-Yes.
-Charli, the first question
is about you,
so please put on
your headphones,
Charli, and play
some music loud.
Give a thumbs-up when you're
ready, and you can't hear us.
Alright, Dixie,
here's the question.
Ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-What is the most normal
teenager thing that Charli does?
-Um, her room basically
looks like a toy store
with stuffed animals,
kinetic sand, Orbeez.
Like, she has
a 5-year-old's room.
-Okay. Okay.
Wow.
-That's what she would say.
-Okay. Here we go.
Alright, good.
The question was, "What's
the most normal teenager thing
that Charli does?"
-Um, probably the fact
that I have a lot of toys,
which is probably the --
[ Bell rings ]
-That matches!
We have one point there.
You just -- That's just normal.
You just love toys.
-She tells me all the time.
She's like, "You're very normal.
Like, it's weird."
-Like, yeah. Alright, Dixie,
your turn to
put on the headphones
and give us a thumbs-up
when you can't hear us.
Okay. Here we go.
Charli, here's the question.
-Okay.
-What is Dixie most likely to do
on a day off?
-Take a nap for the entire day.
-Really? Like, how --
-Yeah.
-Like how long? Like, an hour?
Couple hours?
-Like the whole day.
-The whole day.
-Like a solid five, eight hours.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Wowzers!
Alright, that's interesting.
Alright. Let me ask Dixie. Okay.
-Hi. [ Chuckling ] I'm scared.
-Dixie, here's the question.
"What does Dixie most likely do
on a day off?"
-Probably sleep all day
and watch like Netflix
or something.
[ Bell dings ]
-Oh, my gosh!
You guys know each other well!
This is exactly right.
Okay, for the final round,
Dixie, please
put on the headphones,
give us a thumbs-up
when you can't hear us.
[ Chuckling ] Charli,
here's the question. Ready?
"When is a time
that Dixie broke the rules
that your parents
still don't know about?"
Come on.
-I'm gonna get her in trouble.
She stole my mom's car once.
-[ Gasps ]
-[ Chuckles ]
I don't want
to get her in trouble.
Sorry, Mom.
-Wait, where did --
What are you talking about?
Where did she go?
-I don't know.
She probably went to,
like, a friend's house
or something.
I think she just wanted
to be, like, rebellious once,
and that was it.
She stopped there.
-Was it late at night?
-I have no idea.
I just remember her telling me,
like, "Oh, yeah,
I stole the car."
I was like, "Okay!"
-Does Mom know about this?
-I don't think so.
I hope she does, though, so
I'm not the person to tell her.
[ Chuckles ]
-Okay, very good.
Let's have Dixie take off the --
-Am I good? Good?
-Screaming.
-Oh, am I loud?
[ Laughter ]
-Dixie, the question was,
"When was a time
that you broke the rules
that your parents
still don't know about?"
-Watch her expose herself
for something else.
[ Laughs ]
-It might happen.
-That my parents
still don't know about?
Um...
-Did you sneak out?
-Okay, they know this.
I literally just told them this
a couple weeks ago, though,
but I did steal my mom's car
in high school
to drive to my friend's house.
-Gosh.
-That is correct!
Oh, you're so lucky!
You're so lucky! I wanted
to hear the other story,
'cause you're like,
"Uh, which one?"
You lucked out.
-I was so nervous
she was gonna say
something else.
I was like,
we just revealed two things
that our parents
would not want to know.
-That's what I was waiting for.
I go, oh, my God.
Well, you got a good sister
right there.
You guys are good --
Yeah, you're great sisters.
Congrats on that.
That is "Know Your Sis."
"The D'Amelio Show"
is coming to Hulu this summer.
Thanks so much
for being here, guys.